Speaker 1: An incoming Republican congressman
promoted very strongly by arbiter of ideas. Glenn
Greenwald appears to have made up essentially
his entire back story of his life. This is
quite a story. Business Insider reports incoming
Republican Congressman Jorge Santos reportedly
lied about his employment history, where he
went to college, losing four employees at the
Pulse nightclub shooting and possibly even his
residence. An incoming Republican congressman
from Long Island has several gaps in his resume,
according to a New York Times report. He appears
to have lied about all of the things that I just
mentioned and claimed to have lost four employees
in the 2016 Pulse nightclub shooting. Oh, boy.
The investigation found the following. First,
his description of his employment doesn't add
up. His biography says he worked at Goldman
Sachs. But spokeswoman Abby Collins says there's
no record that he ever worked there. He said he
was an associate asset manager at Citigroup, but
spokeswoman there said it can't confirm he ever
worked there and that they haven't had an asset
management operations division since 2005, which
is five years before he claims to have graduated
college. The Times found no IRS record of a
charity he says he owns. Friends of Pets United
and the beneficiary of a 2017 fundraiser by the
group says they never got any of the money that
he supposedly raised for them. Oh, boy. Secondly,
he's reportedly faced numerous evictions, claimed
to be a landlord and may not actually live at his
current address. He claimed to be a landlord
last year but didn't list any properties.
He was evicted in 2017 from a residence
after owing more than $10,000 in unpaid rent.
Then we get to his educational history. Man,
I should just make up a much more interesting
background. It just seems you could just make
it up. His higher education history appears to
be a lie. He said he graduated with a degree in
econ in finance from Baruch College in New York
City in 2010. Representatives from the school said
they have no record he was ever in enrolled there
despite searching variations of his name.
A biography on the National RNC Republican
Campaign Committee website says he went to NYU. A
spokesman there says they have no record he ever
went there either. Fourth, there is a mystery
as to where his money comes from. And fifth,
he claimed to have lost four employees in the 2016
Pulse nightclub shooting. A review was done. None
of the 49 victims seemed to have any association
with any of the organizations that he even claims
to be associated with. Glenn Greenwald
posted in mid-November. Meet Jorge Santos,
the first ever Brazilian American and first ever
openly gay Republican elected to Congress in U.S.
history. The son of working class immigrant
parents who left Brazil for the U.S. He was
born and raised in Jackson Heights, Queens. Looks
like that didn't work particularly well. You know,
I've wondered before when people just, like, make
up a back story, they make up where they went to
school or whatever. Why are they doing it? Given
that it is, it seems so likely you will eventually
get caught, particularly in a high profile and
public circumstance such as this one. Sometimes
it's this is a way to advance my career or to gain
social status. I can claim to be more qualified.
I can claim to be more accomplished. I'll be
more likely to be hired for a job or promoted
or accepted socially, or maybe more likely
to win an election. Sometimes people will lie
about their credentials out of desperation.
It's a desperate situation. They feel I'm
genuinely not qualified for anything. I need this
opportunity, so I'm going to lie to get ahead.
Interestingly, some individuals are just dishonest
by nature. They're just willing to lie no matter
what, regardless of the consequences. This is what
we sometimes colloquially call pathological lies.
And I've known people like this, people who
just lie all the time for no obvious reason.
They just lie. They always lie. And we don't
know which of these applies to George Santos,
but it is not going particularly well. By the way,
I mentioned he's openly gay. There are some who
are reacting to this with homophobia. Where it's.
It's the right wingers who are saying, you know,
we shouldn't have gone with a gay guy. This
is the problem when you go with a gay guy.
I'm not aware of any evidence that links
gay people to dishonesty. He just seems
to be a dishonest clown. Will there be any
repercussions? Probably not, quite frankly.